[Music]
are you even speaking he's really noise
cancer i can't hear [ __ ] like really i
think she's just moving her lips she
ain't saying anything loud though i feel
like this game only serves to make me
look foolish
[Music]
that's how we should have been doing the
interviews all day whoa
okay
what's my favorite apple i like the
green apple
i like green apples not too sour
caramel i do like them tower what's my
favorite appetizer if i had one listen
it looks like you said what is five
minus one so i'm gonna say four
i like uh oysters
[Music]
high fives
what kind of cream do i like in ashtray
oh a will smith impersonation
locksmith and march is what i got
motivate
motivate you life
motivate
journeys and your journey is not over so
the purpose
of life
is
to find someone
who will light the fire in you
uh you see what i'm saying not on you
that's the worst impression
do you know what just happened i don't
know what happened
uh
signal
favorite
scene stop sign can you articulate a
little bit more when do you sing
together
[Music]
i don't know if i like it big heads big
heads
the camaraderie you know and the love
and the uh
you know expressing something from
honest place i believe i'm in aries
[Music]
hogwarts
i really like fettuccine chicken alfredo
it looked like you said
what am i doing tomorrow and i'm going
to be working all day
it's either what's serendella or what's
grizzabella
isabella she's from cats
oh washington from hijab um algorithms
on tick-tock i don't know
say that one thing uh shooting people
with my friends outside of school
50 cent
you talking to your mama like that
that's not nice you're gonna do well
that's not nice
i'm just gonna say shout out to kansas
city
that's my response because i don't know
what that question was
i suck at this game clearly
i'm sorry
[Music]
you